he's like I gotta go who's Benny talk Oh
is he talking to his wife yeah okay huh
I don't have a carrot it so just before
do you have any carrots have you any
carrots that's not carry those are palms
and berries I really want to be in
Vinny's house right and you're recording
this right now look Larry I'm going with
Arden in my choco still do what do you
only do or if he on the yellow business
don't even know whether or not do we
have any squash in the garden shut the
[ __ ] up brah I want to make some stick
and grow squash in this game what game
were you Blenheim United tennessee for
deal food are you this is like a virtual
garden isn't it it's our virtual girl
okay I thought you who like really had a
garden really sincerity but learning a
lot of great stuff about Benny right now
but like secretly at guards i mean i can
see you like out in your garden like
like tilling the garden yeah on your
hands and knees like planning berries
and stuff like a fine line one day don't
worry you like America okay just don't
forget the carrots okay okay so so I'm
actually making like I'm making tea
right now awesome chamomile tea yeah I'm
gonna sleep well tonight man I was gonna
say I'm gonna be out like a light yeah
let's throw you know uh yeah I mean I'm
all ready whenever you guys I'll be back
guys oh my god really you leave are you
yes goddamn it you know it's almost
three here right yeah it's almost three
years robert e worried were you add like
where do you live I'm in Kentucky oh
that's right you know what I thought it
was Kentucky tiffany has me early she's
like where's Rob live I'm like I think
he lives in Kentucky mm-hmm cuz we're
talking about how like if you guys came
out to Jersey like you guys haven't
actually had real pizza I i have had
pizza believe it or not you had pizza
but not real easy okay you never have
peace until you have sliced chicago but
it doesn't matter cause they should i
like in chicago know like lexington but
it's
Chicago this cold slice of Chicago pizza
he did trust me dude we like oh I was a
oh wait a minute I'm not in batteries oh
hold on one second okay what were you
gonna go to foul I just finish the story
sell forget them Yeah right he'll get
really bad I gotta sit somewhere hold
exoplanets I'm gonna shoot people with
smoke powers okay is everybody here yeah
we're all here I gotta get to me now
does everybody plan on being here for
more than five or six minutes no I gotta
go you gotta go now okay oh damn I could
wait isn't like 3am for you guys yes
where are you at man like is your life
trying to suffocate you with a pillow oh
the microphone isn't my shirt hold on
that better for you yeah it's way better
come in god I imagine your house is like
fortune oh go on vegetables good yeah
wait no I fruits walk out I'm changing
the battery out okay so do we want to go
ahead and eat these stories started cuz
ya alright cuz I'm gonna go to bed
thirty three o'clock in the morning and
we're trying to tell stories about comic
books yeah about life in the comic book
world would you tell a story and we're
not even doing it for the podcast life
in the fast lane no screws just finish
the story now then we'll just record it
on Thursday oh this is getting uploaded
like before thursday all right I'll wait
a moment right are you that hard up for
content no man like it's just gonna be
funny yeah if what if we can actually
get around to it all right here we go so
i'm working at the complex or we're
gonna funny books comics and stuff in
lake hiawatha jersey and so um it's like
it's summertime this is only a couple
months ago i'm working at the store it's
like seven
good night but it's you know summertime
so this the sun's still out the doors
open we're trying to like get some
reason and it's like an hour before
closing and this dude walks through the
door and he's probably like at most 21
he looks like a high-school letterman
football player from like the 60 s like
he is he's an amazing shape he's really
young and he's wearing like a
high-school letterman jacket like with
the varsity letter on and everything and
he comes in the only thing that really
distinguishes that like he's
contemporary is that he's dating a like
Indian woman so like there's some in
there there's actual like you know
progress going on I suppose like him
traveling from the 60s and they come in
she says nothing she says she doesn't
say a word she's just looking around
like they've entered into a museum and
he comes up and he's just he's he starts
casing the place like just looking at
all the all the books on the rack and
he's like looking all the statues but
with like the eyes of a child just
complete wonderment in his face and I'm
like and it bent that at one point my
business acumen kicks in and I'm like
can I help you and he's like yeah man oh
no wait when did that kick it did you
just stare at him for like 20 yeah I
watched him do this for like maybe five
minutes just staring in awe at all the
colleagues well I'm like pretending to
do things but I'm just watching him cuz
like at first I was just like all right
well he's just he's gonna pick up his
books and he's gonna come up and buy him
and leave but like he didn't leave and
he just kept looking at different things
but he wasn't picking up the books he
was just looking at the covers so Wow I
go can I help you and he's like yeah man
do you like do you like any old comics
and I'm like well we really like our
back you should only go back I like
about two or three years because we
really try to keep like everything kind
of new and fresh the store like the the
owner of the store has a whole bunch of
like older books but they're like at his
storage unit because they don't sell and
he's like oh like and I'm like well how
far back you looking and he's like I'm
thinking like like really like really
old I guess like I don't know how old
like he goes these these new comics they
have like like the arts like it's good
but it's just it's not what I remember
it's just it's just really like it's
more like I'm looking at a movie you
know
I'm like yeah i mean like modern comics
kind of really shifted towards that more
realistic style like what's it what's an
artist you're looking for and he's like
like i'm looking for like I burned my
mouth oh [ __ ] under chamomile even your
mic unlike you guilty it's hot do we
have to teach you how to drink tea no
you don't have to teach me how to drink
tea mrs. Holly your garden go tend to
your garden then you grow your carrots
and berries no it's not keratin berries
I'm growing plums in berries the reason
jesus said with me as I don't have
carrots well why don't you have carrots
man because they're not a good seller
right now plums and berries sell better
yeah the carrots are delicious yeah the
carrots so anyway it's kicking Harris um
so uh so I so he's like do you have any
books by like thick like he's like I
can't member the guy he's like the older
guy who like used to draw everything and
I'm like even like like John Romita and
he's like no man I'm like you mean like
Jack Kirby and he's like yeah that's him
I'm like like you remember how you're
younger than me by like a decade so I
correct I grabbed the the Marvel
essentials Thor omnibus from like the 60
s from Ike tales of suspense and I'm
like you mean something like this and he
looks through is like yeah man that's
what I'm talking about like this kind of
[ __ ] right here I'm like I'm like cool
and he flips it over there's like twenty
five dollars man what when did commis
get so expensive I'm like what in the
last 30 years or so I guess if you look
great if you're comparing it to prices
from 1960 [ __ ] six so um he's like
you know I'm like well comics really
come a long way I mean if you want to
see what we've got I'm like I'm not
treating him like a time traveler or
rather I'm treating him like a time
traveler but I'm okay with that like we
always get time travelers yeah and so
I'm like well I mean if you want to
sample something new like let me show
you what we've got like this is kind of
a good sampling so I grabbed like
Constantine off the shelf and I'm like
here you go and he's like yeah man see
this is crazy looking this is like I'm
looking at a movie it's just everything
looks real and I'm like yes I think it's
kind of cool he's like no man like i'm
looking for like the older stuff I'm
like
okay fair enough he goes me ask you
something like what's the Hulk been up
to and I'm like what has the Hulk been
up to well he's been hanging out down at
the bar down the street right well I'm
more like well he's been like what's
your starting point like when was the
last time you read the whole was it 1970
I'm he's done why the last 40 years or
so yeah I'm like well you know like
Peter David took over like in the 80s
and he was smart and then he wasn't and
he split into different colors and then
there's red hulk with Jon anymore I
don't think you want to hear about um
and I go what I mean like if you want to
check out like this is a really
definitive book and I grab planet hulk
he's like this book's $35 there's no way
I can get that my god man he goes I
actually have a bunch of comics like
that I remember when I was a kid like do
you have like that magazine that tells
me the prices of all the comics and I'm
like do you mean wizard magazine and
he's like yeah man wizard magazine and I
go unfortunately wizard magazine closed
in 2011 he's like wow and I'm like yeah
man times have changed like since the
last time you read comics which was I
don't know when and he goes well maybe I
can get him at one of those comic-book
conventions I'm like yeah I guess you
could get some comments at a comic book
convention he goes he goes do you think
there's any nearby like you think
there's gonna be one and he's like and
he's describing these his concept of
what a comic book convention is and it
what a comic book convention was in
nineteen eighty like where you go to the
church basement and you like go through
the long boxes and like I'm like in the
creators are there like Stanley will
appear at like the Brooklyn comic-con it
like the church bazaar I'm like well you
could go to the New York Comic Con he's
like New York yeah like what's that one
like I'm like well you got to get
tickets and he was like we can't just
pay when you get in I'm like no I'm like
well not when you're expecting a hundred
thousand people he's like a hundred
thousand people read comics I'm across
some of them ya know yeah i know they
read comics we're supporting this store
on are you yo cards yeah it's just I was
like this is this is getting more and
more bizarre and he goes he goes like do
you guys sell he goes to do you know
where I might be able to get like like a
a superhero t-shirt like a t-shirt with
like a superhero's logo on it is like do
you think I could get one of those at
the new york comic con I'm like dude I
don't lyrics video I go you can you can
I guarantee you you can get one I'm like
what are you thinking like Superman he's
like yeah like I'm thinking something
more like obscure like flash and I'm
like and I'm looking around for cameras
at this point but like there's none to
be had in the and the woman who's with
him is looking at me like yes my
boyfriend is a time traveler and he's
very concerned about the history of
comics like he really wants to get back
into them but unfortunately he missed
the last 60 years like that's look on
her face she's like yeah he's really
serious we're not [ __ ] with you so um
I go you're thinking you're like at a
prank show like yeah I'm like every way
he's dropping names but like like he
remembers them immediately and I'm like
racking my brain from like 20 years ago
to try and remember like the old stuff
from then and I'm like dude like you're
dropping some science on me but like
he's doing it as a like a jock from the
60s who like maybe had like a closeted
interest in comics like it was just
really really weak so like we're talking
about comic book t-shirts and I'm like
what you could get a thousand comic book
t-shirts at a comic convention but like
if you're looking for just a shirt with
Batman's logo on he's like yeah Batman
that's a great one I go you could
probably just go to the mall and he's
like they sell comic book t-shirts at
the mall and I'm like yeah man you could
just go to like like hot topic or
spencers gifts I mean there's a there's
a kiosk in the middle of the mall that
just sells graphic t-shirts and most of
them are super hero related and he's
like wow and I'm like yeah he's like
well maybe I'm gonna give that comic
book show thing a try he's like honey
would you want to go to the new york
comic book convention and she's like not
really and he's like well maybe i'll
give it a try anyway he goes but but
first let's go to the mall and see if we
can get a t-shirt she's like okay and
I'm like all right guys have a good day
and she gives me this like hey thanks so
much like thank you for indulging him
like kind of
but like so wait so he's acting so she's
acting like someone in the 60s who would
have been like what are you what why are
you into this this no she's she's acting
like she's from 2014 and she's like my
friend here will occasionally slip
between worlds but he's here now but
he's actually born in 1945 so well you
know like that was her reaction she's
like you are really nice to have put up
with this insanity because like the only
person who has that much patience this
man is me like that was the kind of
interaction I had with his girlfriend
and I'm like yeah man that's what we do
here twenty books as we help people you
know whether you're from today or
yesterday like could I have them like
crazy ass people like this guy okay but
seeing like time travel is like this guy
and I'm like I wish I could remember
more details but like most that's pretty
much I hit all the high notes like he he
asked for a copy of wizard magazine to
compare prices of comics he expected
Jack Kirby comics to be readily
available like he was baffled by current
art and prices and he had no concept of
the fact that comic comics and
superheroes were mainstream at this
point like I was like what the hell and
like I I did my best to not act like
that was blowing my mind but he totally
blew my mind something obscure like the
flash yeah like I'm like oh noes
toughest ashes like the flash just
finished his epic reboot of DC like he
is a major freaking player like and I
actually was awarded an even better if
he had said something like go like Green
Lantern somebody have scare like Green
Lantern he did he did mention Green
Lantern like he's like flash of green
lantern and I was like you can get both
those shirts at the mall and he's like
no like never just blew his mind yeah
he's like what he's like honey we should
go to the mall and I can get a green
lantern t-shirt like a good you all lies
you can do all kinds of things in the
mall you can get lunch or you could get
pants
like there's all kinds of stuff you do
there why you can just go hang out and
walk around and look at stuff yeah no
one will tell you to leave yeah you can
look at hot girls that's what I do when
I go to the mall man I just check out
hot girls yeah that's just hot just went
through the roof Rob do what up your
creep factor different no sir no sir
like I'm not the only person I don't
think about securities in there tight
shorts oh god do meet a coworker we were
talking you're not helping being a
co-worker we're talking and well not
really a co-worker a friend of mine were
talking and you're making it worse I'm
not making it worse we were talking
about like big like we're talking about
the wintertime versus the summertime oh
I was ever like man like one of the most
disappointing things in the wintertime
is that the shorts go away and I said
that's true however one of the best
parts of the summertime is that the
shorts are replaced by yoga pants and
sometimes the other pants are better
than shorts ah yes in fact I would say
all the time to be honest yeah I think
you're right have no illusions Rob
Jefferson knows what's up okay dokay got
it just throwing it out there but I did
again it is three o'clock in the morning
so yeah that's fair an item I am tired
because I'm drinking my chamomile tea
and god only knows what I will say it's
true all right well I'm actually gonna
Jack er this one hand here go to sleep
oh we want to go to sleep well that's
great because I'm two hours ahead of you
and I would love to have gone to sleep
two hours ago well you're the one that
answered the call oh that's much fun
yeah because I've been trying to get
information for guys all day and it's
like Oh finally hey I was at work I was
at work all day so I didn't say I was
not able to participate in the skype
discussion earlier yeah however this
conversation has made up for it because
we got to listen to Sal tell weird
stories about a guy who apparently
time-traveled yeah 1860s to the current
day yeah and was baffled by the idea
that you can go to places other than
malt shop and hang out with people yeah
I should have told him like dude if you
want to take this young hot dish out for
a night on the pass would you really
call her
well I would it was more familiar with
you're gonna it's gonna cost more than
two nickels to rub together for a
phosphate at the hardware store like
you're gonna need to really put in some
serious Bank you're gonna it's gonna
take at least a few paper routes this
very tight [ __ ] this tall drink of
water yea Somali yea boy Oh week see you
yeah oh my god i just totally choked to
my it's like I could these are coming up
with all these I can't even come up with
a 1960s like slang term joke like use it
is banging about yeah well I'm old well
I that's that's the trick here Benny is
that I I was that time trailer yes all
right well I'm going to go on to [ __ ]
reboot and watch about how kids just
can't solve the shrine of the silver
monkey yeah by the way bro I should tell
you every emilysoto every episode of
Legends ahem temple is on YouTube hmm if
you just Google if you just YouTube
we're gonna have a video for three days
now huh he's gonna watch that non-stop
we're not gonna get a video from Marvel
explain let's get into now hopefully
he's gonna take on versus you should
make it into four parts release it every
day oh yeah we're gonna refresh Marvel
explain its gonna switch and they'll be
just a big picture of Imhotep and or not
a boat's empty looks like Oakland ohmic
and it'll be a ledge of the hidden
temple show we talked about how great
that show was I made this meme on reddit
and I was talking about how like my
house my apartments like a difficult
place to find and I was like this is how
i imagine giving directions to delivery
drivers and it's like wow how do i get
to your house you could start in the dog
for in the shrine of the silver monkey
yeah i was just looking him up the other
day like actually last night we're
watching Rick Nick reboot cuz you can
get if you you can download that channel
on to your Roku so you can watch it like
it's TV on your bed um by the way you
can't do it direct you got to go on the
website you got ordered like you gotta
you gotta like do a thing but it's easy
enough you got to have the Roku
downloaded yeah but uh we're watching
legends last night and like
dee bradley baker plays Oh Mac and it's
the same [ __ ] guy that plays like
steve smith on american dad and Klaus on
american dad he plays like he's done so
many different voices and he's also
olmec like that's awesome that is pretty
awesome um serious note though um is
Tiffany gonna be on the podcast again
this week because people really liked
her well guys if you guys want her
she'll definitely come out she was she's
always really like she's like are you
sure I wasn't an idiot like did I not
sound [ __ ] know people really
enjoyed it cuz I thought she brought a
really good discussion guys whole idea
of like gender & comics more important I
just found Mexican coca-cola oh [ __ ] yes
that's all that's what I need I need to
see though you to post a link to this
it's great hey hey I don't know is this
picture here I was looking at the heart
attack grill to see this in New York's
and we're all there we can all just
heart attacks a heart attack grill if it
is in nevada but they just did like the
pictured here a heart attack burger with
fries in mexican coca-cola it specifies
mexican oh yeah you can get mexican go
cold at costco it's just it uses cane
sugar instead of high fructose corn
syrup oh my god that sounds so good and
so bad I'll leave it in that [ __ ] man i
need i need some of Benny's carrots and
fruits now I need to get oh wait to
carry them there's ok before i bounce
off her there's a place here in town at
the metaphor cafe that has a dish called
the itis and yeah it is a bacon double
cheeseburger between to krispy kreme
donuts uh that is basically Jim Gaffigan
sketch then look at mcgriddle here comes
the doughnut ham hamburger like they
made it after the episode of the
boondocks called the office yeah there
was such an awesome episode you ever
watch the boondocks Benny yeah yeah I
love that show ya did it was it was a
major night they made a whole town go to
sleep so I'm gonna go ahead and drop off
now guys alright with you guys in the
morning alright cool alright letter C